Generally big businesses have a very few
manufacturing units so they cannot go to each
person and deliver the products then they deliver it
to shops which in turn
sell it to
people so in this case the cost price will be
the cost for the shop it is  The price at which
the shop buys the products from the
factory and the other minor costs that the shop incurs
and the selling price will be The
price at which the shop will sell it to the
people Let's imagine The shop buys it from the
factory at ₹  10 And Sells It To The People
At
₹1 The Shop Has Sold It At A Higher Price Than Its
Costs Since It Is In Profit Now
Assume That The Shop Has Orders From The
Factory But The Demand For The Products
Has Suddenly Dropped The Cost Price Still
Remains ₹10
but because of the low demand the shop decides to
sell it to the people at
8 in this case the shop incurs a loss notice
that in the first case the selling price was
higher and in the second case it was lower in
short if  If the selling price is greater than the
cost price then the product will be
profitable but if the selling price is lower than the
cost price then it will be a loss
making product and if the selling price
is equal to the cost price then it is a
no.  Profit No Loss
Situation All You Need To Know Is That If The
Price At Which You Sell Is Greater Than Your
Overall Costs You Are Making Profits But If It's The Other Way Around
You Are Making A
Loss Cost Price Is Generally Known As CP
And Selling Price  Is it generally known as
a The problems based on profit and loss are very
simple Let us see a few basic
examples
Consider the cost price e 10 and the selling
price e 15 Is it a profit or loss since
the selling price is greater than the cost
price  We can set it is a profit and what is
the profit is
equal to the selling price minus the cost
price that is 15 m 10 f equ 5
A profit of ₹ means that the product was sold at
₹ higher than the cost
price  Now consider the cost price is 10 and the
selling price is 7 Since the selling price
is less than the cost price we can
say that it is a loss and how is the loss
calculated Loss is equal to cost price minus
the selling price that is 10  - 7 Which
is in the first case we see a profit of
money and in the second case we see a loss of money. If you find
the formula confusing follow this
procedure first by looking at the CP and
the SP find out if it's a profit.  And a
loss and then subtract the lower number from the
higher
[music]
number